Speaker 1: I want to start today by talking
about President Joe Biden's upcoming Supreme
Court pick.
As many of you have no doubt heard by now,
the oldest liberal justice on the court, Stephen
Breyer is going to be retiring and Joe Biden
is going to get to pick or nominate rather
a replacement, which is subject to confirmation
by the Senate now.
Joe Biden made a promise during the campaign
that he would select a black woman, which
would be, if confirmed, the first black woman
ever on the United States Supreme Court.
He confirmed that that's still the plan.
Jen Psaki, his White House press secretary,
confirmed it, and I believe Joe Biden has
also been asked about it and confirmed that
as well.
The American Right is now starting a campaign
to make the case that this is extremely discriminatory
and essentially racist to anyone who is not
a black woman.
In other words, the way that many are framing
it and we're going to look at Laura Ingram
in a moment, who's doing this is if you are
excluding anyone who is not a black woman,
it is by definition, discriminatory and or
racist against those individuals.
This is wacky.
And as someone who is not a woke stir and
not into corrosive identity politics, I'm
going to explain to you why these people are
wrong.
But let's first listen to Laura Ingraham.
Speaker 2: Like everything else, Joe Biden
touches his Supreme Court selection process
is in shambles.
Candidate Biden, he thought he was being really
woke and so cool by pledging to nominate an
African-American woman to the High Court.
But of course, he was also effectively discriminating
against a vast majority of the adult population.
Oh, and now even liberal websites like Slate
thinks he has himself in a bind, claiming
that Biden's pledge has backfired and needlessly
tokenized future nominees.
Speaker 1: So let me remind you, I am not
an identity politics guy.
I have spoken out for a decade about uses
of identity to silence or to exclude you all.
You've been watching this show listening to
my podcast for a while.
You know that.
Let's go through this now in that context,
in steps.
First of all, is what Joe Biden is doing unique.
And the answer is no, it is not.
Here is Donald Trump saying I'm choosing between
women only for this next scene and the crowd
cheered Greene.
Speaker 3: I will be putting forth a nominee
next week.
It will be a woman.
Speaker 1: Right?
It wasn't only Donald Trump who did this.
Ronald Reagan did the exact same thing.
Speaker 3: Polls continuing to show he runs
better among men than women.
Reagan took a dramatic step today to reach
out for female support.
Now I'm announcing today that one of the first
Supreme Court vacancies in my administration
will be filled by the most qualified woman
I can possibly find.
Speaker 1: Oh whoa, hold on a second.
Now you can say, Well, they were all wrong
to do that, David.
OK, fine, you could take that position.
But were you actually saying it at the time
or are you saying it now that they already
put women on the courts and you no longer
really have to say anything about it?
It's very easy now to say, Well, they were
all wrong.
None of them should have done it, but that's
not really the most important thing to think
about.
I'm putting for context that this is not unique.
So a lot of the criticism of Biden is hypocritical,
but the most important thing is the context
that matters here.
The Supreme Court was established in 1789,
from 1789 until 1967.
That's 178 years.
Every single justice was white and male.
OK, one hundred and seventy eight years and
during that time, we had slavery in the United
States for roughly 80 years of that 178 years.
We had slavery of black people and an all
white male court.
So it's OK.
And it's notable when we say, Hey, we now
have a black person on the court, which came
in 1967 with Thurgood Marshall.
It's not racist.
It's not discriminatory.
It's look at the makeup of the country and
look at the makeup of the court.
And at this point, with so many qualified
black jurists, how have we not had one?
It's OK to point that out.
You're not participating in toxic and corrosive
identity politics.
Let's give another example from 1789 until
1981.
We had all men on the court.
That's one hundred and ninety two years.
Every single justice was a man.
So it's OK.
And notable to say, given the history of qualified
women lawyers, judges, here's finally the
first.
The woman on the court when Sandra Day O'Connor
was nominated to the court, there has never
been an Asian person on the Supreme Court.
Native American, Pacific Islander, black woman,
Indian-American, etc.
We don't need a court that exactly matches
the makeup of the U.S. in every turn, every
every sort of demographic characteristic.
Nor is it even possible with only nine people
on the court.
But at a certain point when you say, Wow,
we have 330 million people in the country
now, the Supreme Court's been around more
than 200 years.
It starts to get weird that we have not had
certain people on the court.
Now they start to play its identity over qualifications.
They say we're ignoring who are the most qualified
people because we're focused on identity instead
of qualifications.
And again, that's a terrible argument.
Once again, we're a country of three hundred
and thirty one million people.
If I were to say or if Joe Biden were to say,
I am going to pick the first former sports,
oh OK, current or former sports team owner
who is a woman, we would say, Wow, that's
like a really small group.
There's not a lot of female major sports team
owners.
It's like, you know, Renee Montgomery and
Michelle Williams from Destiny's Child as
a part owner of a team and Jeanie Buss owns
parts of multiple NBA teams.
We might be saying that's really weird.
That identity designation is not appealing
to appearing to be a pool of qualified people.
Joe Biden is picking one black woman, and
there are many qualified black women.
There is no reason to believe that by saying
I'm going to pick a black woman and it's going
to be notable, given the history of the country
in the history of the court, there's no reason
to believe that it's going to be a less qualified
individual.
You're picking from among the many qualified
black women.
It is such a non-story, and that's me as a
non woke non identity person, not identity
politics person telling you this, but they're
going to keep playing it up and they're going
to make it into something that it is not.
If you disagree with me, I would love to hear
from you.
Respectfully, of course.